back then could have predicted that 14
years
later the snp would be re-elected
for a fourth consecutive term as
scotland's government
and absolutely no one would have
predicted the scale
and the record-breaking nature of our
victory
at this election now we don't yet have
confirmation of the final result
but we do know that on a record turnout
the snp has won 62 constituency
seats or on course to do that
that is a higher number than ever before
and it would be an incredible 85 percent
of the total and we haven't just held
every constituency seat that we won back
in 2016.
we've also gained seats from both labour
and the tories
and recorded our best ever share of the
constituency vote
indeed we have won more votes and a
higher share of the votes in the
constituency ballot
than any party in the history of
devolution
this election result is by any standard
an extraordinary
and historic achievement we took our
positive message
of hope and recovery to every corner
of our country and it has been endorsed
emphatically by the people of scotland
my heartfelt thanks go to all of those
in the snp
who worked so hard in such difficult
circumstances
to make all of this possible i also send
my warm congratulations to successful
candidates from all political parties
and of course my commiserations to those
who have lost out
i know from personal experience how
tough
that is but most of all i want to
thank the people of scotland for putting
their trust
in me and in the snp once again
we will work to repay that trust every
day
over these past 14 years the makeup of
the scottish electorate has changed
16 and 17 year olds can now vote
and seeing so many of our young people
engaged
and energized inspires real hope for the
future
and in this election for the very first
time
foreign nationals and refugees were able
to vote as well
a tangible symbol of the inclusive
country
that we are on thursday morning in my
own constituency i met with
syrian refugees who had just cast
their first votes here in scotland it
was a
deeply emotional moment for them and as
a country
that should make us really proud
so my message today really is for all
of scotland and it is this one
whatever you are from whatever age you
are whatever your background and no
matter who you voted for
the snp in government is dedicated
to working for you i pledge that the
task of building
a better scotland for everyone who
chooses to live here
will be my priority every single day
as first minister of course my immediate
and overriding task
will be to do everything i possibly can
to keep us
all as safe as possible while we are
making real and positive progress now we
have not
yet beaten covet during this campaign
i said that tackling the pandemic must
come first for as long as it takes
and i meant that i will be returning to
work
straight away to take the decisions that
will guide our next steps back
to normality and on to recovery
in this election the snp put forward an
ambitious
and transformative programme to
kick-start and drive our recovery from
this pandemic
so we will now get on with the job of
delivering
that program that means the
re-mobilization of our nhs coupled with
the investment it needs
to secure it for the future a new
national care service
investment to support new green jobs and
re-skill people for the future
a youth guarantee to secure
opportunities for our young people
action to tackle the climate emergency
and ensure
a just transition more houses better
schools
and an unwavering commitment to lifting
children
out of poverty the policy program we put
before the people of scotland
will move our country forward and it
will make it better of that
i have no doubt but while we
are understandably and rightly focused
this weekend
on our own election results here in
scotland
the results of the various contests
south of the border
reveal and underline an important truth
about scotland and the rest of the uk
the majority of people here in scotland
back a progressive
inclusive outward-looking vision for the
future
of our nation and yet we are facing
many more years of right-wing
brexit-obsessed
tory governments that we don't vote for
taking us
in a direction that we have not chosen
that brings into very sharp focus a key
question
that was posed at this election how do
we best secure
the kind of country we want to build
and just as we said in this election
it is why the people of scotland must
have the right
to decide our own future when the covert
crisis
has passed this is now a matter of
fundamental
democratic principle already
today i hear opposition parties and some
commentators
talking about what they call snp demands
for an independence referendum they're
desperately trying to
rewrite the basic rules of democracy and
redefine what constitutes an election
win
and a mandate and of course i hear the
usual talk of boris johnson refusing to
give in
to those demands and all the supposedly
clever maneuvers
that westminster might be planning
all of this all of this risks treating
voters in scotland and our entire
democratic process
as if they simply don't matter like they
are just a sideshow
voters are not a sideshow it is you
not me not boris johnson not any
politician
but you who are the people who matter
and so let us be clear about what
scotland voted for
on thursday the people of scotland have
voted to give
pro-independence parties a majority in
the scottish parliament
now the final numbers may not yet be
known
but it is beyond doubt that the
pro-independence majority
in our new parliament will be larger
than it was
in the last one both the snp and the
scottish greens stood on a clear
commitment
to an independence referendum within the
next
parliamentary term and both of us made
clear
that the timing of a referendum should
be decided by a simple majority
of msps in the scottish parliament
so in no way can a referendum be
described
as just a demand of me or of the snp
it is a commitment made to the people
by a clear majority of the msps who have
been elected
to our national parliament it is the
will
of the country and given that outcome
there is
simply no democratic justification
whatsoever for boris johnson or indeed
for anyone else
seeking to block the right of the people
of scotland
to choose our own future and let me
be very clear about this if the
tories make such an attempt they won't
be
placing themselves in opposition to the
snp
they will be standing in direct
opposition to the will
of the scottish people and they will
demonstrate conclusively
that the uk is not a partnership of
equals
and astonishingly that westminster no
longer sees it
as a voluntary union of nations that
in itself would be a most powerful
argument
for scotland becoming an independent
country
of course holding a referendum does not
mean that scotland will automatically
become
independent that will be a choice for
the people of scotland
and the task for those of us who support
independence
is to make that case and to persuade our
fellow citizens
with patience and with honesty of its
merits
that is what the snp intends to do
so let me set out the task ahead for me
and for your re-elected snp government
first and foremost it is to lead
scotland
through the pandemic and to keep the
people of this country
as safe as possible that will be my
focus
when i return to my desk tomorrow it is
then to kickstart and drive a recovery
from covet
with that ambitious and transformative
programme
for government and yes when the crisis
is passed it is to give people in
scotland the right to choose
our own future all of that is what i
promised in this election
and all of that is what i intend to
deliver
but first it is time now for me to get
back to work
to lead this country through and out of
the covert crisis
thank you so much for the trust you have
once again
placed in me i promise to serve all of
the people of scotland
with integrity with energy and with an
unwavering commitment
to building the better scotland that we
all know
is possible thank you